so what'd you get angry at me because I
want you to keep fighting the good fight
I want you to never take that no and let
it hurt you or allow you to crumble I
want you to say okay you know what I I'm
done reading for you yeah I'm gonna read
my own I'm gonna write my own I'm gonna
read my own I'm going to work with
people that I know can do it because I'm
playing destiny oh that's what it that's
what it comes that's what it is I
already told you I [ __ ] it already told
you know that I'm addicted to destiny
and I'm at a point where I'm gonna
either I'm gonna it's it I'm gonna play
it and then until out to get to the
point where I get so depressed that I'm
gonna change and then I'm gonna do it
and that's it I'm just telling you
that's why I said all the things I said
before is because I'm motivated by pain
and suffering I'm not motivated by when
good things happened and this has been
my best year in so long it's just this
little a been so consumed with destiny
and if somebody would just take me to
the lighthouse
you got a lighthouse we're done no I'll
go to lighthouse two or three times
because I have a tight bond holder I
told you that last time is good thank
you but I'm done talking about my you
know I mean my career or you know I
don't people want to listen to that
people don't want to hear it and I get
it and it's my life and I talk the way
doing can I just say this right now that
I was just at the Comedy Store and this
young ethnic lady walked up to me and
she said I'm a big target really fan she
gave me a hug she goes I want to go see
your brother so I'm from Minnesota I'm
gonna go see your brother show tomorrow
night you know and I'm just a big fan of
your guys's all deep the deal and I know
that there's a lot of people listening
that are like that and and and the truth
be told the truth be told this is the
thing
because I'll tell you why can I tell you
why George if you want to listen to me
okay his years ago I was I ran into
Marilyn rice cub who I love I've met her
husband I love her kid she was on 24 she
was on the TV show 24 I'm a big fan of
the 24 shows and um she just I just
she's just intrinsically likable I see
her we hug and whatnot okay but I saw
her at comedy clubs a lot when she was
that the tail end of her they are
working on 24 and I go why the [ __ ] are
you doing comedy you know I mean like
you're on a show she I know but I want
to create you know a franchise with my
name mm-hmm you know me I want my name
to be the thing right and I believe that
this thing right here I can look because
I'll be honest with you I wasn't keeping
up with the Joneses no one's ever said I
loved you in that movie my dad thank you
a couple of people said I loved you on
Zoey's or Zorn right or whatever but
this is where most people go I'm here
because of this right so at the end of
the day this is it like the stroke song
album this is it right and maybe for me
I'm looking at all these different
directions going where's my life going
and I just put my listen I'll be honest
with you last night when I was doing the
photo shoot with kalila I was looking at
her and I saw how Paul was looking at
her the photographer and he was like ooh
la la you know and they're like you know
it's like look it up you know cuz he's
kept saying this is this fort is amazing
because look at how beautiful she is
look at how you look like [ __ ] tapioca
know she's with you say that a couple
times I just said it yeah like you look
terrible and I go you don't belong with
her fake abs you know I go yeah I don't
belong with her and yet I am with her
and I have this podcast
and I tour and I have a great agency
behind me I have everything already so I
[Laughter]
wrapped a full [ __ ] circus oh [ __ ] it
this was not I'm not gonna lose weight
I'm gonna beat ya and I'm gonna die like
this this is the best sweetie yeah no
this was not contemplated
[Music]